I'm an artist and I guess we did a good
job and Lady Gaga opens up about her
steamy performance with Bradley Cooper
at the 2019 Oscars vaga was a guest on
Wednesday's Jimmy Kimmel Live where she
basically said social media went off the
deep end
analyzing shallow people started saying
like oh you they must be dating must be
in the app first of all like like social
media quite frankly is the toilet of the
Internet yes pop culture is just like
abysmal and and and yes people saw love
and guess what that's what we wanted you
to say Gaga said because Bradley
directed their film a star is born she
fully trusted his vision for their
Oscars performance the camera angles the
lighting everything from a performance
perspective it was so important to both
of us that we were connected the entire
time when you're singing love songs
that's what you want people to feel
earlier this week a source close to Lady
gaga
opened up to et about her bond with
Bradley explaining quote the Oscars
filled their love story even more but
what really happened behind the scenes
of the Oscars was a sweet conversation
between the two of them Lady Gaga
thanked Bradley for making her dream of
becoming a movie star come true and
Bradley thanked Gaga for making him a
rock star in many ways is the end of an
incredible journey what does it meant
and what does this journey meant to you
especially with Gaga in the hope all the
folks from as far as that you know what
its
you can actually tell a story get a
group of people together and then make
it and then have it been received the
way it has I'm just happy to be here in
the presence of such incredible artists
I mean so much talent in this room and
it's been my dream since I was a little
girl that I would be able to even you
know work as an actress to work as a
musician to make it in this world back
on Kimmel Gaga celebrated a stars born
being re-released into theaters this
week and turns out you could even bump
into her in your local theatres in the
theatres
yes with like real paying customers yeah
yeah yeah I squatted in the back with
the popcorn like hiding and then I sneak
in 30 minutes out cause like the end of
the movie so sad that I can't take it so
I'm just like crying with my popcorn
[Music]